- I'm a (bleep) critique, a critic.
I'm a critique critic.
When I was a kid and we
had taco night at my home,
I would eat 30.
- What is there not to love about tacos.
- Drunken adventure, three in the morning,
20 tacos, let's go.
- My favorite place to get
tacos is probably Chipotle.
- Favorite fast food taco would
probably be Jack-in-the-Box.
- I just love Mexican food.
- I don't even have to like, taste it.
I can just look at it.
You already know that this is going to be
the Jack-in-the-Box taco.
- These ones are the greasiest,
they have like the grease
on the actual tortilla.
- First off, this looks
like a big ravioli.
- The meat just like, soothes your soul.
- Is that meat or beans?
- Um, it's very creamy meat.
- It's a good in-between with
a crunchy and a soft taco.
- Yeah, well, I think actually these are
from Jack-in-the-Box.
- It might be from
Jack-in-the-Box because I assume
that Jack-in-the-Box makes
tacos that looks like that.
- I definitely think
this is Jack-in-the-Box.
- I don't know, I don't even
know what my options are.
It's from tacos plus.
- This looks like high school lunch tacos.
- I definitely think
there's like taco seasoning
of some sort, that this one
has that the first one didn't.
- Not (sigh).
- By the way, none of these are Mexican.
- Mine just fell apart.
- Now this tastes what my mom use to make.
And I'm sorry mom, but
you're just not good
at cooking tacos.
- Yeah this is just the most
generic, like Gringo taco
that's like ever been put together.
- A lot of this meat has
a nicotine type quality,
where I don't like it, I
know it's not good for me,
but for some reason, I just want more.
- I think it's Del Taco.
- We're going to say this is Taco Bell.
- Taco Bell.
- I think this is from K Rico Tacos.
- Why Rico? Why?
- Got a little tomato up in here.
- Well balanced of like, all
the ingredients in one bite.
- It's missing taco sauce.
- This one could easily
be Del Taco I think.
- Yeah.
- I think it's Taco Bell.
- Yeah, Papa John's taco.
- This one looks
- This is gorgeous.
- I've been waiting all night for this.
- This one has beans in it, and rice.
This is like a burrito but it's a taco.
- This meat's cooked.
- It's not ground.
- It's cut.
- Cut.
- Someone put their time into
putting this taco together.
- Mine's falling apart and I don't care
because this is delicious.
- I feel like this is Baja
Fresh because it's so fresh.
- This is El Pollo Loco.
- Chipotle.
Or fancy Taco Bell.
- Jack-in-the-Box.
- Jack-in-the-Box
ding ding ding.
- Taco bell.
- No.
- Wow
- Taco Bell wasn't so bad.
- Are you sure?
- Del Taco
- No way.
- Clearly, we're killing this.
- Oh my god.
- Chipotle? They have tacos?
- Aw, (bleep).
- Oh, why didn't we think of Chipotle?
- Yeah.
- Chipotle is like a
guy in a business suit
and these three people are in college.
- If you think I'm cute
while eating tacos.
- Comment below.
If you think I'm cute, leave a like.